[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
لي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من بغداد التي شهدت
احتجاجات على السماح بحرق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف امام السفاره العراقيه في ستوكه
والى البيت الابيض الذي قال المتحدث باسمه
الى الولايات المتحده شاهدت اشارات على ان
روسيا تستعد لمهاجمه سفن مدنيه تحمل
الحبوب في البحر الاسود
والى اسفل فيه ولايه كوليرادو
حيث تتواصل فعاليات منتدى اسفل للامن حول
التحديات الدوليه في مجالات الامن القومي
والسياسه الخارجيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
واستجد لنا اشعلته خطه لحرق نسخه من
المصحف الشريف احتجاجات وازمه دبلوماسيه
بين العراق والسويد الحكومه العراقيه تطرد
سفيره السويد والسويد تستدعي القائمه
بالاعمال العراقيه
انتقادات دوليه لاقتحام السفاره السويديه
في بغداد وايران تستدعي السفيره السويدي
للاحتجاج على التدنيس المتكرر للمصحف
بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه تجدد
الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم
ومدينه الاوبيض جنوبا وفي تصريحات للجزيره
ولولايه الجزيره يكشف عن تشكيل لواء من
عشرين الف مسلح لمنع انتقال الحرب واثرها
الى الولايه
بعد ضربات روسيه على اوديسا وميكولايف
وصفتها اوكرانيا بليله جحيم كيف تقول ان
موسكو تستهدف البنيه التحتيه لموانئها
لمنع اي اعاده تصدير محتمله للحبوب
الاوكرانيه البيت الابيض يقول لناروسيا قد
تستهدف حركه الملاحه المدنيه في البحر
الاسود وروسيا تنفي وتقول انها دمرت
مستودعات للقوارب المسيره والدخيل
وفي لقاءنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مسار الازمه بين العراق
والسويد مظاهرات في بغداد احتجاجا على
السماح بحرق نسخه من المصحف والعالم
العراقي في ستوكهولم بغداد تطرد السفيره
السويديه وتسحب القائم بالاعمال في
ستوكهولم وسلطات السويد ترد بالمثل
لاستطلاعى ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي
ما مسار الاحداث المتوقع بعد اقتحام
السفاره السويديه في بغداد الاجابات جاءت
على النحو التاليه عشرون في المئه قالوا
ان الازمه الدبلوماسيه ستشتد بين العراق
والسويد بينما صوت 44 في المئه لصالح خيار
تصاعد موجه الغضب الشعبي في انحاء العراق
في حين رجح سته وثلاثون في المئه احتواء
الازمه عبر اتصالات الدبلوماسيه بين
الطرفين
اذا هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الذي يظهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وسط التحذيرات نتنياهو من رفض الخدمه
العسكريه مقطع فيديو تمثيلي مثير للجدل
لهجوم الاسرائيليين افتراضي
جنديا اسرائيلي يطلق نداء لطلب دعم جوي
الطيار يساله هل انت مع التعديلات
القضائيه ام ضدها
[موسيقى]
بيان للحكومه العراقيه ان رئيس الوزراء
محمد شياع السوداني قرر سحب القائم
بالاعمال العراقي لدى السويد
واكد مسؤول في مكتب رئيس الوزراء العراقي
للجزيره انا بغداد قررت طرد السفيره
السويديه ياتي هذا بعد اقتحام متظاهرين
لمقر السفاره في بغداد احتجاجا على قرار
السويد السماح لمظاهره امام السفاره
العراقيه في ستوكهولم يجري خلالها حرق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف
[تصفيق]
في بغداد غليان لا تخبو جدوته مظاهرات
جديده هذه المره مؤيده لقرار الحكومه
العراقيه قطع العلاقات مع السويد اصوات
طالبت ايضا بانهاء اي مصالح للحكومه
السويديه في العراق سبق ذلك اقتحام انصار
التيار الصدري للمره الثانيه في اقل من
شهر مقر السفاره السويديه في العراق
السفاره السويديه ببغداد اضم المحتجون
النار في مبنى السفاره فيما اعتبروه ردا
على حرق نسخه اخرى من المصحف الشريف امام
السفاره العراقيه في ستوكهولم
وفي النجف حذر زعيم التيار الصدري من
تصعيد جديد حاله تكرار حرق نسخه اخرى من
المصحف الشريف ثم ادعو دول العالم الى سن
قانون يجرم حرق القران
ويجعله جريمه ارهابيه كما ان التعدي على
الساميه
والمجتمع الميمي يعتبر جريمه فلابد ان
يعتبر حرق القران ايضا جريمه والا كانت
هذه ازدواجيه في المعايير الديمقراطيه
والحريه
الحكومه العراقيه وخلال اجتماع امني طارق
حضره وزير خارجيتها استنكرت حرق السفاره
وقررت احاله الضالعين في الحادث على
القضاء والمقصرين من المسؤولين الامنيين
على التحقيق اجراءات اعقبها قرار بطرد
السفيره السويديه من بغداد واستدعاء
القائم بالاعمال العراقيه لدى ستوكهولم
بلغوا بهذا الشكل لكنهم قدموا مبررات
نعتقد نحن انها ام غير حقيقيه لكن للاسف
ما حدث ايضا ليله البارحه نحن نعتقده ايضا
حدث خارج السياق في البيان الامني المهم
اليوم اعتبر عمليه الهجوم على السفاره
واعتبرت الحكومه عمليه الهجوم على السفاره
السويديه في بغداد خرق امني
في هذه الاثناء توالت ردود الفعل المحليه
والدوليه بيان لبعثت الامم المتحده في
العراق استنكر اقتحام السفاره السويديه
وقال ان مكافحه خطاب الكراهيه بالعنف لا
ينفع بينما ايدت القوى السياسيه في البلاد
قرارات الحكومه العراقيه
اغلقت السفاره السويديه ابوابها واوقفت
جميع المعاملات القنصليه اجراء على بداهته
يبدو مقدمه لازمه دبلوماسيه قد يطول امدها
سامر يوسف الجزيره من امام السفارات
السويديه في بغداد
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان المنظمه الدوليه تتابع بقلق التطورات
بشان السفاره السويديه في العراق واضاف
كان تدنيس الكتب المقدسه واماكن العباده
امر غير
مقبولنس
نتابع هذه التطورات بقلق بما في ذلك ما
رايناه خلال المظاهرات من ادراهم للنار في
السفاره السويديه ما نحتاجه والاحترام
المتبادل اعتقد اننا كنا واضحين جدا وقلنا
ان تدنيس الكتب المقدسه وتدنيس اماكن
العباده امر غير مقبول من المهم ان لا
يتفاعل الناس مع الاستفزازات ولكن من
المهم ايضا ان يحترم الناس بعضهم البعض
وان يحترموا ديانات بعضهم البعض
اما الخارجيه الامريكيه فدانت بشده الهجوم
على سفاره السويد في العاصمه العراقيه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان عدم تحرك
قوات الامن العراقيه لمنع المتظاهرين من
اختراق مجمع السفاره السويديه للمره
الثانيه امر غير مقبول واضافه انه يجب الا
تكون البعثات الاجنبيه اهدافا للعرس كما
دعت الحكومه العراقيه للوفاء بالتزاماتها
الدوليه لحمايه جميع البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وشددت على ان حريه التجمع السلمي سمه
اساسيه للديمقراطيه معتبره ما حصل ليله
الماضيه عملا من اعمال العنف غير القانوني
وينضم الان الينا من بغداد الدكتور حسين
علاوي مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي دكتور
حسين اهلا بك في الحصاد
الحكومه يا هلا بك الحكومه العراقيه اتخذت
اجراءات
بحق حكومه تقول ان ليست لديها اي سلطه
لايقاف ما حدث
ما الذي تتوقعونه من هذه الاجراءات التي
اتخذتمها
يعني اكيد هذه الاجراءات التي قامت بها
الحكومه العراقيه وكذلك بالمقابل باتجاه
عمليه الخرق الامني الذي حصل بتقدم
متظاهرين ومحتاجين الى السفاره فجرا ومن
ثم
عمليه يعني اتخاذ اجراءات امنيه باتجاه
القوات الامنيه الماسكه وكذلك بالمقابل
القاء القبض واصدار امر قضائي من مجلس
القضاء الاعلى على مجموعه من قاموا بعمليه
حرق ومن ثم كذلك تحذير اطلقته الحكومه
العراقيه للحكومه
السويديه بضروره منع عمليه تدنيس
القران الكريم يعني عمليه الحرق للقران
الكريم وكذلك العالم العراقي من قبل احد
المتقدمين للحصول على اللجوء والمطلوب
للقضاء العراقي وفقا لمذكره صادره من مجلس
القضاء عبر الانتربول العراقي الى
الانتربول الدولي حقيقه لم تتوقف
جعل الحكومه السويديه والشرطه السويديه
تقوم على ما يبدو بعمليه التسريع بالدفع
باتجاه هذه الحادثه المؤلمه في الذهن
العربي والاسلامي وهذا بالتالي ما جعل
من بين الاثنين مليون مليار نسمه في
العراق في ان يظهروا مره اخرى
باحتجاج رسمي داخل العراق ومن ثم جعل كذلك
بالمقابل الحكومه العراقيه تتخذ قرار بسحب
القائم بالاعمال في السفاره العراقيه في
السويد وكذلك بالمقابل
دعوه الطاقم والدبلوماسي الممثل بالسفيره
وكذلك الطاقم الدبلوماسي للسفاره السويديه
بالرحيل من مغادره العراق وهذا بالتالي ما
جعل الازمه الان الدبلوماسيه تشتد بين
البلدين لكن كان من المفروض الا تذهب
الحكومه السويديه والشرطه السويديه في
اعطاء رخصه حرق المصحف الشريف وكذلك
العالم العراقي ما يمثله من تاثير في
الوجدان
وقع ما وقع واشتدت الازمه كما قلت دكتور
حسين هل هناك مطلب واضح مثلا من الحكومه
السويديه
قدمتموه سواء كتابه او شفهيه بحيث اذا تم
الالتزام به او الاستجابه له يمكن النزول
من الشجره ويمكن للامور ان تعود الى مجرها
الطبيعي
رئيس الوزراء الاستاذ محمد الشياع
السوداني كان يقود هذه الازمه بصوره فعاله
وهو ذهب باتجاه عمليه حمايه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
ومواجهه هذا الخرق الامني من خلال اجراءات
اداريه وتحقيقيه وكذلك جزائيه وجنائيه
ولكن بالمقابل دعا الحكومه السعوديه
الشرطه السويديه مساله اذا كان هناك مطلب
محدد قدمتموه للحكومه السويديه بحيث اذا
التزمت به يمكن الامور ان تعود الى سابق
عهدها
طبعا هذا هذا يعتمد على اجراءات الحكومه
العراقيه خلال المرحله المقبله سواء في
الاجتماعات التي سيجريها السيد رئيس
الوزراء الاستاذ محمد الشيعه السوداني
وكذلك توجيهي لوزاره الخارجيه العراقيه
بعقد قمه طارئه لمؤتمر دول التعاون
الاسلامي وهذه الدعوه حقيقه من الحكومه
العراقيه قد لاقت ترحيبا من قبل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكذلك تركيا وغيرها
حقيقه من الدول الاسلاميه الاخرى وايران
وغيرها من الدول الان التي بدات كذلك تصدر
مواقف رسميه عبر وزارات الخارجيه وكذلك
لجماع الداخلي الذي دعم السيد رئيس
الوزراء بهذه الخطوه وكذلك بيان البرلمان
وبالتالي ستظهر طبعا مطالب
للحكومه العراقيه وكذلك
الوقت في هذا المسار يمثل
يعني مشهد احراق السفاره هذا لقى انتقاد
كبير من عده جهاد هل هناك اجراء يعني واضح
ان الغضب الشديد سواء من جانب الحكومه او
من جانب الشارع ايضا هل هناك اجراءات يمكن
ان تتخذوها لمنع خلط الاوراق حتى لا يتم
التركيز على هذه النقطه وترك القضيه
الاساسيه
اكيد هذا الخرق الامني تم اتخاذ اجراءات
اداريه
وقانونيه من قبل القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه للاستاذ محمد الشاعر السوداني
باتجاه القوات الماسكه ومسالته كيف تم
يعني
ذهاب المحتجين الذين هم لديهم مطالب كبيره
باتجاه عدم حرق القران الكريم وعدم حرقه
كذلك العلم العراقي بعد الدعوات التي
تلقوها على السوشيال ميديا
والنظروا بها اشكرك دكتور حسين علاوي
مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي كنت معنا من
بغداد انا الى استوهم
وشتين
فيد مال استاذ العلوم السياسيه المختص
بتسويه النزاعات في جامعه اوبسالا اهلا
وسهلا بك في الحصاد اذا اذا السؤال هو
الذي يطرح نفسه هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يحصل فيها شيء من هذا القبيل استفزت
مشاعر المسلمين من قبل ولكن الامر يتكرر
رغم اعتراضات داخل السويد نفسها من
الحكومه ومن الشعب لماذا يسمح بتكرارها
اولا السلام عليكم وشكرا لاستضافه هذا
اليوم وهذه لحظات حرجه ومن المهم ان يقال
ان
السويد في نظام ديمقراطي علماني يسمحوا
بكل انواع الاحتجاجات طيله الوقت بغض
النظر عن ما اذا كانت مسيئه
النصوص مقدسه في السويد نحن لدينا قوانين
تعود الى العمل 1766 والتي تحفظ حق حريه
التعبير هناك قله يحتاجون بهذه الطريقه
واعتقد انه سيكون
اظهارا
للضعف من جانب الحكومه
السويديه اذا ما سمحت لقله من الناس ان
يؤثروا في الامور بهذه الطريقه ولكن
هناك يعني انطباع عام في العالم العربي
خصوصا والاسلامي بان هناك شيء من
الازدواجيه في المعايير يعني
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مليئه بفيديوهات
عن اسر عربيه تشتكي من
اولادها يتم ازالتهم من عندها فقط لمجرد
حديث عن مجتمع الميم عن اراء معينه فيما
يتعلق بهذا الامر او بما يتعلق باسرائيل
وما الى ذلك فيعني هذا الموضوع الذي اثير
على اكثر من مستوى كيف ترد عليه السويد
اذا ما شاهدت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وجدت ان هذا مسرح لمعلومات مظلله ممثلون
يقومون بتقديم
مشاهد عن اختطاف اطفال مسلمين في السويد
هذا مجرد تفضيل وتزييف
المثليين في السويد لديهم حقوق هذه ليست
قضيه في السويد هناك طبعا القضيه هي في
عدم الاعتراف بهذه الحقوق يعني من جهه
هناك عدم قبول لاي شخص يمس بكتاب مقدس
ولكن ليس هناك قبول لاي شخص يمس بحقوق
المثليين مثلا يعني الى جانب امور اخرى
مثل الساميه وما الى ذلك فهذا هو هذا هو
ما نتحدث عنه المعايير على العموم يريد
ايضا ان اسالك عن موضوع يتعلق
باستعداد السويد لابداء شيء من المرونه
والتنازل مثلا فيما يتعلق
بانضمامها
كان هناك ضغط من اجل ربما
موضوع يتعلق بالتعامل مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني وبالفعل تم تغيير قوانين قانون
الارهاب في السويد من اجل ذلك اذا لماذا
هذه المرونه في مواضيع ومرونه في مواضيع
اخرى وعدم مرونه في مواضيع اخرى
اولا
اقول لا توجد هناك ازدواجيه في المعايير
لدينا قوانين قويه تحفظ حقوق الافراد
والمجموعات لكن حريه التعبير في السويد
تفيد بانك اذا دنست
نصا مقدسا هذا ضمنا نطاق حريه التعبير لو
كانت هناك
جرائم كراهيه ضد المسلمين هنا يتم
معاملتهم بوفق القانون لا توجد معايير اما
فيما يتعلق بالتنازلات في مفاوضات
الانضمام الى
النيتو على الحكومه السويديه ان تجيبهم عن
ذلك انا عالم سياسه لست ممثلا لحكومه ولا
نتدخل انا باحث مستقل اشكرك وكباحث مستقر
ربما سالتك اذا كانت هناك قدره او استجابه
لضغوط ومن ثم سؤال عن نوع الضغوط التي
يمكن ان تمارس في هذا الخصوص تحديدا اشكرك
من ستوكه
[موسيقى]
المختص بتسويه النزاعات في جامعه اوكسلا
الان الى ملف اخر يتعلق بالسودان اذ قصف
الجيش تجمعات للدعم السريع في مواقع عده
جنوبي وشرقي الخرطوم وفي ام درمان وفي
مدينه الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان دارت
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله كما قصف
الطائره حربيه مواقع للدعم السريع
بلا حسم تستمر المعارك في مختلف محاور
العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في شرق العاصمه وجنوبها اغار
سلاح الجو صباحا على عده مواقع للدعم
السريع التي اتهمها الجيش في وقت سابق
الاربعاء بقتل واصابه نحو 30 مدنيا في
هجوم بطائره مسيره على منطقه العزوزاب
جنوب الخرطوم جنوب العاصمه ايضا قال الجيش
ان قوات العمل الخاص التابعه له نفذت
عمليات في حي العشره شرق مقر سلاح
المدرعات كما قصف الجيش بالمدفعيه مواقع
لدعم السريع في حي المعموره وعلى اطراف
المدينه الرياضيه
وفي غرب ام درمان وشمالها شن الجيش
السوداني هجوما بالمدفعيه الثقيله على من
يصفها بالمليشيا المتمرده على ان اكبر
مواجهات الخميس دارت بعيدا عن العاصمه
تحديدا في مدينه لوبيض على بعد نحو 600
كيلومتر جنوب غرب الخرطوم المدينه التي
تعتبر خط امداد لقوات الدعم السريع من وسط
ولايه شمال كردفان شاهدت اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله لا سيما في جزئها الغربي
والجنوبي قبل ان تشن الطائرات الحربيه
غارات ردت عليها قوات الدعم السريع بنيران
المضادات الارديه وتحدث سكان عن اصابه عدد
من المدنيين في تلك المواجهات
وهذه ولايه الجزيره وسط السودان التي باتت
ملاذ عشرات الاف النازحين فرارا من الحرب
لكن سلطات الولايه تقف عاجزه عن تلبيه
احتياجاتهم المراكز بتاعت اليواب بتاعتنا
هي اكثر من 150 مركز بتاع المراكز دي
بتتراوح عدد الاسر فيها يعني من 250 الى
300 الف يعني في المتوسط
ده جزء من الناس البارين طبعا زي ما قلتها
بتاويهم الاسر بالنسبه للوالي فان النائيه
بولايه الجزيره عن المواجهات لا يقل اهميه
عن توفير المساعدات وتعزيز جهود الاغاثه
فيها عندنا اصلا لواء هيتم تشكيله في شركه
جزيره اللوداء بيحتاج لمجندين المجندين
بدينا في اجراءاتهم
الدعوه او التوجيه بتاع القائد العام ممكن
يصادف هون في المساله دي وسرعه بانه
ضمينا قدام المحاربين او الذين يعرفون كيف
يتعاملوا مع السلاح لانه الان ذاهب ابقوها
منطقه امنه ذلك هو التحدي الاكبر فايطاله
امد الحرب خطر داهم يتهدد كل مدن السودان
وليست ولايه الجزيره من ذلك استثناء
معنى الانفلس الدكتور اسامه عيدروس
الاكاديميه السودانيه المختص في الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه اهلا وسهلا دكتور
اسامه
افق للحل هل تراه يعني واضح ان هل هناك
مؤشر لذلك للاسف هذه الحرب العالم دخلت في
شهرها الرابع المعاناه من اهلنا معاناه
كبيره جدا يعني
الجرائم ترتكب بشكل يومي ومستمر
قتل على الهويه اغتصاب تهجير من البيوت
تضييق على الناس يعني جعل الحياه مستحيله
مع تدمير كل مقدرات الدوله
المؤشرات العسكريه تقول انه يعني القوه
نفسها قوه النخبه التي بدات هذه الحرب
بقرض الاستيلال الحكم انتهت انتهت كقوات
انتهت كسلاحها المؤثر والمباشر انتهت
الخطط العسكريه التي وضعتها لانها من
البدايه بدات بخطه انتشار واسعه في بيوت
المواطنين وهذه الخطه استراتيجيه وعسكريا
فاشله لم تحقق لها اي هدف عسكري ظلت كل
المعسكرات القويه للجيش المؤثره على مسيره
المعرفه نفسها سير العمليات زلت قويه
متماسكه اظل الجيش يتقدم الى الامام بعد
ان فشلت كل خططها العسكريه واهداف
العسكريه هذه القوات الان مخندقه يعني
بالمصطلح العسكري داخل بيوت المواطنين
وتستخدمهم كدروع بشريه وهي الان في حاله
دفاع
عندها خيارين الخيار الاول ان تستمر في
حاله الدفاع وتكون بالتالي عرضه للعمليات
الخاصه او لهجوم بري من الجيش ينهي هذه
العمليات
الخيار الثاني ان تحاول ان تجمع اطرافها
ويعني هي دائما تجتمع بما يسمى الفزع اي
تجمع كل اطرافها وتهجم على معسكر كبير ان
كل طرف يتحدث عن غصن زيتون
هناك استعداد لذلك ولكن على الارض لا يحدث
شيء بالضبط انا انا رغم التفاؤل في تفاؤل
حذر الان في الساحه السودانيه عن امكانيه
احداث تقدم في مفاوضات جده انا على العكس
ارى انه الملف مثقل الان يعني جرائم نهب
الاموال من الخرطوم اكثر من 50 مليار
دولار تم نهبه من الخرطوم
وخرجت منهوبه سيارات المواطنين مدخراتهم
البنوك غيرها كلها هذه خرجه الشيء الثاني
ملف الجنائيه والجرائم التي تكشفت لكل
العالم الان الادانات اصبحت واضحه يعني في
بدايه المعركه كان هنالك غطاء واسع دولي
لقوات الدعم السريع وحديث عن خلاف بين
الرجلين قوتين في الخرطوم جيشين طرفين
طرفي النزاع لكن الان ادانات الدعم واضحه
لكل يعني من الكل حتى الذين يتحاملون على
الجيش السوداني الان يرون هذه الجرائم راي
العين المحاسبه على هذه الجرائم ايضا هو
ملف ثقيل جدا ومعقد لان هناك طرف ايضا سمح
لهذا الطرف بان يمتد وان يصل الى موصل
اليه على العموم هذا موضوع يطول فقط اردنا
ان نمسك باطراف خيطه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المختص
في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض ان الولايات المتحده شاهدت
اشارات على ان روسيا تستعد لمهاجمه سفن
مدنيه تحمل الحبوب في البحر الاسود وقد
عبرت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض اوليفيا
دالتن في احاطه غير مصوره عن قلق واشنطن
من الهجمات الروسيه على الموانئ
الاوكرانيه قالت اوكرانيا من جانبها انها
ستعامل بالمثل السفن المتجهه الى روسيا في
البحر الاسود بعدما اعلنت موسكو في وقت
سابق ان السفن المبحره الى الموانئ
الاوكرانيه ستعامل على انها حربيه واعلنت
مناطق جنوب البحر الاسود مناطق خطيره
للملاحه وقد شهدت مناطق البحر الاسود
هجمات
استخدمت فيها بشكل متزايد مسيرات بحريه
وعيد متبادل بين روسيا واوكرانيا في البحر
الاسود مباشره بعد اعلانها توقف العمل
باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب قالت روسيا انها
ستعتبر اي سفينه متجهه الى الموانئ
الاوكرانيه ناقله محتمله لشحنات عسكريه
وطرفا في الصراع واعتبرت جنوب شرقي وجنوب
غربي البحر الاسود مناطق خطيره للملاحه
الان ترد اوكرانيا وتقول ان جميع السفن
المتجهه الى موانئ روسيا او الموانئ
الاوكرانيه المحتله مؤقتا حسب وصف وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ستعتبر حامله باسلحه
وسيتم التعامل معها على هذا الاساس واضافت
ان التنقل سيحذر في شمال شرقي البحر
الاسود ومضيق كيرش ينيكال لم يكفي الطرفان
بالوعيد والتهديد فقد شنت روسيا هجمات
قالت انها استهدفت منشات عسكريه ومخازن
ذخيره في اوديسا وميكو لايف وهما من اهم
موانئ تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه اما
الرئاسه فقد قالت ان الهجمات الروسيه
استهدفت عمدا محطات الحبوب بهدف واضح هو
تدمير امكانيه شحن حبوب اوكرانيه اعتبرت
الهجمات الروسيه ردا على استهداف مسيرات
بحريه جسر كيرتش الذي يربط بين روسيا وشبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها عام 2014 اكد
الهجوم الدوره المتزايده الذي اصبحت تلعبه
المسيرات البحريه الى جانب الجويه في هذه
الحرب لم يتوقف تصعيد في البحر الاسود
واشتعلت النيران قرب مدينه ستاري كريم
جنوبيه شبه جزيره القرم حيث مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي
وتحدثت مصادر في شبه الجزيره عن هجمات
ومسيرات جويه وبحريه في مايو الماضي دمرت
روسيا اخر سفينه اوكرانيه كانت تدعى يوري
اوليفارينكو بميناء اوديسا فزادت كياف من
اعتمادها على المسيرات البحريه تنتج
اوكرانيا مسيرات بحريه وحصلت على اخرى ضمن
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه ورغم امتلاك
روسيا اسطولا بحريا ضخما فقد بدات تعتمد
ايضا على المسيرات البحريه بدقتها في ضرب
الاهداف والانخفاض تكلفتها خصوصا البشريه
ينضم الان الينا من مدينه كانسس مات دومك
المدير السابق لمكتب روسيا فيغان ومن
موسكو ينضم الينا
محرر الشؤون الدوليه في صحيفه كوميرسان
اهلا وسهلا بكما وابدا معك سيد ستروكن اذا
الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن ليالي جحيم
واضح ان هناك حمله تصعيد من روسيا
وتستهدف اوديسا وميكوليف تحديدا
ما الهدف
من الواضح ان روسيا اتخذت القرار
بالانسحاب من اتفاقيه
الحبوب وهذا اضاف الضغوط على هذا الموضوع
ومجال تصدير الحبوب ولكن بعد يوما من
انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق الحبوب من غير
الواضح كيف سوف يؤدي ذلك الى نتائج عمليه
انتم على حق روسيا اعلنت بشكل رسمي انا هو
بعد الانسحاب من اتفاقيه الحبوب كل السفن
يمكن ان تصبح هدفا شرعيا للجيش الروسي
ولكن الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل كما يقال
نحن لا نعرف كيف سوف يعمل ذلك على ارض
الواقع من وجهه نظر الشخصيه لا اعتقد ان
روسيا سوف تستخدم حقها بالهجوم
اي سفينه تظهر هناك طبعا يمكن ان يكون
لديها الحق ولكن تحتفظ بحق عدم تنفيذه
وبالتالي لربما تستخدم روسيا حقها فقط في
حال وجود ادله قويه بان بعض السفن تنقل
ليس الحبوب بل معدات واسلحه واي شيء يمكن
ان يستخدم في النزاع العسكري وبالتالي
القصه الان ليست مرتبطه بقصف الشحنات او
السفن التي تنقل
الحبوب روسيا ليست مجنونه لكي تقصف هذه
السفن والهدف الرئيس الانسحابي من اتفاقيه
الحبوب كان بوقف شحنات الاسلحه والمعدات
غير المرتبطه
باتفاقيه الحبوب وايضا اوكرانيا رفعت
السقف عندما تحدثت وقالت انها سوف تقصف
السفن الروسيه ولكن في الوقت نفسه ونظرا
لوضع الراهن بعد انسحاب روسيا
لم نرى اي طلقه من الجانبين فقط اما نراه
هو خطابات عاليه النبره ولكننا لسنا
متاكدين الى اي حد سوف يذهب الطرفان
ما هي الرؤيه الامريكيه
لهذه الموجه من التصعيد الان واستهداف
اوديسا وميكو لايف تحديدا
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تراها هذا
التصعيد على ما عليه وهو ان الحكومه
الروسيه تقوم بخرق القوانين الدوليه بشكل
كامل وخصوصا المتعلقه بحريه الحركه في
المياه وتقوم روسيا بذلك بشكل علني وليس
هذا بالامر الجديد لطالما خلقت روسيا
القوانين الدوليه لا تبه بشان القوانين
الدوليه اصلا وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ترى هذا الامر على حقيقته روسيا
تستفيد من قوتها من اجل التاثير على
صادرات الاوكرانيه من الحبوب والحاق الضرر
بالاقتصاد الاوكراني ومنعها من تصدير
حبوبها لدول العالم التي هي بحاجه الى ذلك
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تود من تركيا
والصين والدول الاخرى ان تضغط على روسيا
باكبر قدر ممكن للعوده الى نوع من
الاتفاقات التي تؤدي الى تصدير الحبوب
يعني اذا السيد
الولايات المتحده تقول ان روسيا ستستهدف
ناقلات الحبوب ولكن اليس صحيحا ان كل شيء
مباح في الحرب وفي الحب كما يقال في
النهايه روسيا قد تفعل ذلك
وما الذي يمنعها من ذلك الان يعني في هذه
المرحله
هل والسؤال ربما السؤال اذا سمحت حتى فقط
اتم الفكره اذا قبل ان تجيب يعني في
النهايه
الولايات المتحده مقبله على موسم انتخابات
واذا كان الامر سيتم في تجويع العالم بسبب
نقص في الحبوب هذا ايضا سيلعب دور هل يمكن
ان تتغير المعادله
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الى الجزء الاول من سؤالك روسيا
اكثر من قادره على ارتكاب الفضاءات
باستهدافي السفن التي تقل الحبوب في البحر
الاسود
وروسيا لديها النيه وطبعا من ناحيه اخرى
السفن سوف تخشى ان تبحر في البحر الاسود
لانها لا تود ان تخاطر وهذا سوف يؤثر
بالتالي بالنسبه الى مساله الانتخابات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمجاعه في
العالم ودور ذلك داخليا في الولايات
المتحده انا اشك بذلك لان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديها الكثير من
الصادرات في مجال الحبوب من المزارعين
الامريكيين وطبعا الارقام جيده هذا العام
قد يختلف الامر في العام المقبل ولكن لا
اعتقد ان هذا سوف يؤثر بشكل اساسي بنسبه
الى زاويه الانتخابات في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سيد
اذا كانت روسيا قد قدمت يعني افضل ما
لديها نقول افضل ونحن في الحرب ليس هناك
ما هو افضل ولكن من حيث الهجوم
والهجوم المضاد والحاله التي نحن فيها
يمكن هل يمكن وصفها بحاله
الميت لانه لا غالب ولا مغلوب كيف يمكن
الخروج من هذه المرحله بطريقه
تحفظ ماء الوجه لكل الاطراف
وتجنب العالم ماساه وكارثه حقيقيه
في البدايه اود ان ارد على ما تفضل به
السيد الدمك لقد خاب ظني بهذا الخطاب الذي
يكرر الروايه الامريكيه طبعا لا نود ان
ندخل في لعبه اللوم ونلقي اللوم ومن هو
الذي يلام بالعوده الى اتفاقيه الحبوب
اولا بشكل اساسي نحن دعمنا هذه الاتفاقيه
منذ عام من الزمن
وكان لدينا امال كبيره معلقه على هذه
الاتفاقيه ولدينا اسباب بعد سنه من الزمن
للانسحاب من هذه الاتفاقيه بالنسبه الى
الربط بين هذا الامر والنزاع العسكري وما
تفضلت بطرحه من سؤال من غير الواضح
بالنسبه الى هذه الصفقه
وما مدى الارتباط ومدى المسار الذي سوف
يتخذه هذا النزاع اوكرانيا كانت تشن هذه
العمليه المضاده وسلط الضوء عليها
ويمكننا ان نرى عمليه اوكرانيه ولكن في
الحقيقه اوكرانيا تواجه مشاكل جمه في هذه
العمليه التي اطلقتها والحقيقه هي ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلفاء
الولايات المتحده في الغرب يطوقون
للوصول او لايصال الاسلحه السحريه بين
مزدوجين لاوكرانيا كي تكسب ولكن لا تتمكن
من ذلك اشكرك اشكرك للاسف مضطره للمقاطعه
اشكرك سيد
محرر الشؤون الدوليه في صحيفه قمر سانت
وشكرا
لمات دنك المدير السابق لمكتب روسيا فيغان
من كانسيس
[موسيقى]
حضر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو من مخاطر الدعوات لرفض الخدمه
العسكريه على خلفيه الاحتجاجات وقال ان
هذه الدعوات غير ديمقراطيه وتمس بامن
اسرائيل مضيفا ان الجيش يخدع للحكومه ولا
يخضعها بحسب تعبيره
رفضوا الخدمه العسكريه هو نهايه
الديمقراطيه ويشكل خطرا على امن كل
الاسرائيليين في النظام الديمقراطي الجيش
يخضع للحكومه ولا يخضع الحكومه عندما
تحاول جهات داخل الجيش وعن طريق التهديد
املاء سياسه الحكومه هذا امر مرفوض واذا
نجحوا فعلا باملاء تهديداتهم فهذه هي
النهايه الديمقراطيه يجب على كل مواطن اي
يعارض ذلك بحزم
انتشر في اسرائيل
عن تقديم الغطاء الجوي لجنود في وحده مشاه
خلال نشاط عسكري في لبنان يظهر الفيلم
الطيار وهو يسال احد الجنود في الميدان ان
كان يؤيد التغييرات القضائيه في اسرائيل
وعندما لم يجب الجندي تتعرض وحده المشاه
الانفجار شديد وربما لقصف من قبل سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي ذاته اثار الفيلم الدعائي
غضبا شديدا في الاوساط الاسرائيليه
تمضي الحكومه البريطانيه قدما في تنفيذ
سياستها الخاصه بطالبي اللجوء الذين يصلون
البلاد بشكل غير نظامي وقد اعلن المتحدث
باسم العوامه
انه سيتم ربطها خلال الايام المقبله بشبكه
المرافق العامه في ميناء بورتلاند وذلك
استعدادا لاستقبال الفوج الاول من طالبي
اللجوء في بريطانيا وذلك في خطوه
استهجمتها كثير من الهيئات والمنظمات
الحقوقيه
واحده من عده عوامات تسعى الحكومه
البريطانيه لايواء طالبي اللجوء فيها
بالاضافه الى قواعد عسكريه سابقه بمجرد
وصول العوامه الى بريطانيا شرعت السلطات
المعنيه في ربطها بشبكه المرافق العامه
توطئه لملئها بطالبي اللجوء في اقرب فرصه
خطوه اثارت غضب حقوقيين
انه امر شائن في هذه العوامه شيدت ايام
220 شخصا لكنها ستستخدم لواء 500 المساحه
لكل لاجئ ستكون صغيره للغايه
اغلقت الحكومه الطرق الشرعيه للجوء امام
من يخاطرون بحياتهم ويعبرون القناه
الانجليزيه او البحر المتوسط في هذه
الرحلات الطويله والخطيره سوران ينتظر
البته في طلب اللجوءه منذ عامين وسياسه
الحكومه تزيده غضبا على غضب ارفض تماما
هذا القرار المتعلق
بالاجبار اللاجئين على اسطول العسكريه
ونقلهم الى اماكن
الجابريه والقسريه اصول العوامه رافقته
تظاهرات لمؤيدي اللاجئين واخرى لمعارضيهم
وبعضهم من تيارات اليمين المتطرف تظاهرات
وتظاهرات مضاده تطورت احيانا الى تلاسن
واشتباكات تقول الحكومه ان ابقاء طالبي
اللجوء في فنادق يكلف سته ملايين جنيه
استرليني يوميا وهذا ظلم للمواطن
البريطاني وقد نجحت اخيرا في سن قانون
يسمح بالاعتقال والترحيل السريع لمن يصلون
الى البلاد بشكل غير نظامي اما الى بلدهم
او الى بلد ثالث لقرون ظلت بورتلند مدينه
هادئه ومدخلا للواصلين الى جنوب بريطانيا
لكن برسوي اولى عوامات ايواء طالب اللجوء
فيها صارت المدينه
نقطه ساخنه في جدل محتدم بشان سياسه
الحكومه البريطانيه في التعامل مع ملف
الهجره واللجوء اسعد الله الصاوي الجزيره
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على سياق
اجتماع عقده اليوم وزراء دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لبحث سبل التقارب مع تركيا عقبات
قبول دوله الاتحاد الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
انضمام تركيا الى التكتل ليست قليله
وتتغير بتغير السياسات داخل تلك الدول
لطالما شددت تركيا في طلبها المتجدد لدخول
البيت الاوروبي على موقعها الجغرافي
والاستراتيجي من ابعاد متعدده ومختلفه فمن
انضمامها للنيتو عام 52 من القرن الماضي
تعتبر تركيا
نقطه ارتكاز للحلف نحو منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هي ايضا بوابه لدول جنوب وشرق بحر قزوين
خصوصا الجمهوريات الاسلاميه الخمس في وسط
اسيا وهذه الاخيره تعد مركزا للطاقه
بعد
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا وازمه الطاقه
العالميه تعززت امكانيه تحول تركيا
مستقبلا الى مركز للطاقه ونقطه عبور مهمه
للغاز الطبيعي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ربط
موافقته على انضمام السويد الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي باعاده اطلاق مفاوضات انضمام
بلاده الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
تركيا بدات مفاوضات انضمامها عام 2005
بسبب ملفات مختلف عليها بين الطرفين
بعد ذلك ادركت الدول الاعضاء عام 2018
تحديدا انها في طريق مسدود وذلك بسبب
قرارات اتخذتها انقره واعتبرت مخالفه
لمصالح الاتحاد الاوروبي
توترت العلاقات بين بروكسل وانقره كثيرا
بعد محاولات الانقلاب الفاشله في انقره في
يوليو 2016 وحمله الاعتقالات التي اعقبتها
وطالت معارضين وصحفيين معروفين
ومنذ فرضت تركيا سيادتها على الثلث قبرص
الشماليه عمى
باتت الجزيره مقسومه بين جمهوريه قبرص
العضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي وجمهوريه شمال
قبرص التركيه التي اعلنت من جانب واحد عام
1983 ولا تعترف بها سوى انقره
بعد ازمه الهجره عام 2015 ابرم الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اتفاقا مع تركيا بهدف في
الحد من وصول المهاجرين الى اوروبا مقابل
الحصول انقره على مساعده ماليه كبيره
الان ينضم الينا من باريس زياد ماجد استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في
باريس اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور زياد اذا تركيا
منحت النيتو اغلى واهم ورقتين
السويد
وفنلندا هل حان وقت المكافاه
نعم اعتقد ان تركيا ستحصل بالمقابل على
عدد من مطالبها لكن لا اظن ان الانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون يسيرا او حتى
ممكنا في المستقبل القريب والمتوسط تستطيع
تركيا في المقابل ان تعيد احياء مساله
الاتحاد الجمركي مع اوروبا وهذا امر
اقتصادي حيوي بالنسبه اليها تستطيع
التفاوض حول تاشيرات الدخول للمواطنين
الاتراك الى اوروبا وهذا ايضا امر يسهل
الحركه كثيرا بالنسبه لرجال الاعمال
وللمواطنين الاتراك لكن مساله الانضمام
مساله معقده لانه كما تفضلت حضرتك
بالتقرير موضوع قبرص موضوع اشكالي هناك
تحفظات من فرنسا ربما تكون المانيا هذه
المره هي الاكثر دفعا باتجاه اعاده احياء
المفاوضات للحاجه الاقتصاديه والموقع
الاستراتيجي
وخوفا من تبعات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا لكن مساله الانضمام دونها الكثير
من الصعوبات ولكن دكتور ماجد يعني الان في
في شيء بالحماس يعني الكل متحمس لان تركيا
اظهرت هذه التنازلات
وهم في المقابل ربما يعطونها شيء من
التنازلات ولكن السؤال هل هذا سيرضي تركيا
وهي عينها على عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني لم لم تخفيها ابدا هذا هو الهدف
والمراد هل سيرضيها ما تقدمه
لا اعتقد ان الاداره التركيه للمساله
الاوروبيه سترضى فقط بتقديمات اقتصاديه
لكن في نفس الوقت يمكن اذا دخلت تركيا في
الاتحاد هذا الجمركي اذا جرى رفع تاشيرات
الدخول عن مواطنيها اذا احيت مسارات عديده
كانت معلقه منذ خمس سنوات ترتبط بالشروط
الاوروبيه فيما يخص الاقتصاد وفيما يخص
ملف حقوق الانسان وفيما يخص دور الجيش في
الحياه السياسيه التركيه وهنا كان هناك
تناقض اوروبي يعني بين هذا المطلب وبين
الصمت عن محاوله الانقلاب هذه الامور يمكن
ان تشكل بدايه لتركيا في لحظه رغم عناصر
القوه التركيه انما اقتصادها يحتاج ايضا
الى استثمارات اوروبيه يمكن ان تاتي وما
زالت تركيا تملك اوراق اخرى تماما من
الدقيق القول انها قدمت اكثر ورقتين جوده
ربما في المفاوضات لكن مازال هناك موضوع
اللاجئين ما زال هناك موضوع
الوسطات بين البحر الاسود والبحر المتوسط
فيما يتعلق بالصادرات الاوكرانيه
دكتور ماجد انه يعني هذا لا يرقى للورقتين
الاهم اللي كنا نتكلم عنهم اللي هي السويد
وفنلندا في النهايه انتهت برايك يعني
ربما كان يمكن لتركيا ان تلعب هاتين
الورقتين بطريقه مختلفه هل كانت ستستفيد
اكثر برايك ما الذي دفع تركيا لهذا لتقديم
هاتين الورقتين على طبق من ذهب
لحلف النيتو بهذه الطريقه
هناك براي موضوع اساسي بالنسبه لتركيا هي
تعيد الى حد ما تموضعها في العلاقات
الدوليه لن تتخلى عن العلاقه مع موسكو وعن
قدرتها على التواصل والتفاوض والوساطه
معها ومع الصين ومع دول اخرى لكن هناك
تقارب من جديد غربي تركي ربما يكون هناك
وعود امريكيه فيما يخص بطلبات تركيا
المرتبطه بالتسليح المرتبطه بامن حدودها
وطبعا موضوع احياء المفاوضات مع اوروبا
ممكن ان يكون جيدا هناك قدره لتركيا قبل
شهر اكتوبر وهو الموعد المزمع لدخول
السويد او لبدء مسار دخول السويد ان تطلب
شروطا اضافيه ان تحسن موقعها التفاوضي لكن
الضغط على تركيا كان كبيرا للقبول بالسويد
واعتقد ان الخيار هو ايضا خيار تموضع
استراتيجي في الحلف الغربي مقابل احياء
الاقتصاد وعلاقاته وعوده البحث
بالعضويه الاوروبيه ايضا فقط اشير ان
تركيا في موضوع اليونان خفضت التوتر
والنزاع وهذا الى صالحها لصالحها لكن
مازال هناك مساله قبرص ومسائل مرتبطه
بالحدود المئويه
يعني اليونان دائما هي التي تلعب الدور
الاكبر فيما يتعلق على الاقل هذا ما يظهر
هل سنشهد تغير في هذا خصوصا انه في كثير
تصريحات في الفتره الاخيره حتى من وزيره
المانيا يعني اكثر مرونه من اي وقت مضى هل
اليونان ايضا ستظهر شيء ربما بهذا الاتجاه
اليونان لم تعلق بشكل سلبي الطرف الوحيد
الذي علق سلبيا هو قبرص فيما يتعلق بمساله
وحده الجزيره انما اليونان كانت صامته
والتقرير الذي تبناه البرلمان الاوروبي من
يومين وهو تقرير سلبي فيما يتعلق بالعضويه
لكنها منفتح على مفاوضات اخرى يمكن ان
يجري التطرق اليه من جديد انما الواضح ان
المانيا هي اكثر من يدفع باتجاه عوده
المفاوضات وطبعا السويد وفنلندا
ستكونان ضمن هذا الاطار الدافع مقابل مع
ما جرى لكن ما زال هناك موانع في بروكسيل
من قبل اداره الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي عدد من
العواصم في اوروبا الغربيه تحديدا دكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اذا وصلنا للختام ونختم بالازمه
الدبلوماسيه بين العراق والسويد كما بدانا
هذه الازمه تذكرنا بما يتردد هنا وهناك
ومن وقت لاخر من حجج تتذرع بحريه التعبير
لتبرير انتهاك المقدسات والتعدي على ثقافه
الاخر لكن بالاضافه الى ادله على ازدواجيه
معايير تثبتها وقائع وتفاصيل كثيره لا
يمكن باي حال وباي ذريعه تبرير افعال تؤجج
الكراهيه والعنف وتهدد قيم التعايش ولا
نتيجه لخطاب الكراهيه المبني على المعتقد
او العرق او الدين سوى المزيد من الكراهيه
والتمييز والتحريض والعنف عبر العالم
والامل كل الامل ان تعلو في عالمنا مبادئ
الحوار والتفاهم المشترك وتسود قيم
التسامح والتعايش بين اصحاب الديانات
والثقافات والاعراف المختلفه
تصبحون على عالم اكثر تسامحا
[موسيقى]